London police say this morning that
manslaughter charges are possible in the
devastating apartment tower fire
investigators are focusing on an
appliance as the cause of last week's
inferno at least 79 people were killed
when flames quickly engulfed the 24th
storey building materials on the
exterior may have helped spread those
flames British authorities are racing to
examine other buildings across the
country Jonathan Vigliotti is near the
scene of the fire in London with the
latest on this story Jonathan good
morning the morning gale and
investigators continue their work inside
this building this morning police say
the fire was not deliberate even so key
questions remain about whether enough
was done to prevent it the fire that
engulfed the 24 story Grenfell tower
started in a faulty refrigerator in one
of the apartments according to British
police detective Superintendent Fiona
McCormick I can't confirm that the
numbers that we have of presumed beds
confirmed dead or missing that still
remains at 79
with nine people being formally
identified as dads the search for bodies
could take until the end of the year and
investigators fear they may never find
everyone who died in the fire they are
closely examining the building's siding
or cladding as it's known in the UK and
how the tiles and insulation were
installed the cladding failed
investigators tests for combust ability
British authorities are now aware of at
least 11 other buildings that have
combustible cladding that will now need
to be removed known in the trade as
aluminium composite material or ACM the
cladding in cases a polyethylene core
that is flammable fire tests have shown
extreme heat can melt the cladding
allowing fire to ignite the polyethylene
core underneath spreading flames quickly
the material is banned in the US and
parts of Europe on any building over 40
feet that firefighters can't reach with
ladders but the UK hasn't followed suit
when she returned to Grenfell Tower
residents booed Prime Minister Theresa
May over the government's handling of
the blaze she's called for a full review
which could take weeks a new york-based
company are connick whose product was
used as one of the components in this
cladding says they welcome this British
investigation Norah in one of their
brochures they say this kind of cladding
never should have been used on any
building more than 32 feet high all
right Jonathan Vigliotti in London thank
you